alors voilà donc cette installation de
breatest analyse dans une banlieue chic
de la côte Est avec femme et enfant
c'est du pipeau mitter raconte comme
c'était son autobiographie c'est là où
c'est génial
bonsoir
t'inquiète merci
que vous soyez là en considère que vous
êtes le plus grand écrivain américain
vivant
je sais pas quoi dire maintenant alors
vous êtes comment dit bêtement l'enfant
terrible des lettres américaines mais
au-delà de ça vous êtes une star
littéraire comme peuvent l'être en
France Michel Houellebecq ou Frédéric
Beigbeder c'est-à-dire que vous faites
souvent la une des médias pour des
raisons qui ne sont pas que littéraires
vous dites la célébrité est un
anéantissement une sorte de mort
bratishtonelli ce n'est pas moi c'est
tout ce que les gens qui ne me
connaissent pas ont dans la tête à mon
sujet
ce qui se passe c'est que tout à coup
votre propre personnalité est parti il y
a ce faux
le même droping le sexe et la violence à
outrance le héros c'est un golden boy
qui est aussi un serial killer
et c'est un livre qui a provoqué aux
États-Unis des réactions absolument
paroxystiques vous dites en me menaçait
de me couper le pénis et de me violer
avec une batte de baseball
hérissée de clous
commis dans le livre lui-même oui c'est
tout à fait exact c'est agréable de
recevoir ses lettres c'est-à-dire qu'à
ce moment-là on vous a confondu avec
votre héros
que je me faisais l'avocat de son style
de vie de son comportement si vous lisez
ce livre c'est le moment et si vous ne
lisez pas si vous ne comprenez pas que
c'est une satire et bien à ce moment-là
bon vous ne comprendrez pas le livre
tout simplement parce que le livre c'est
une comédie noire
Patrick beitman j'ai toujours pensé que
c'était un personnage très très
idiot très un fou en fait et les gens
qui ont pris le livre traite au sérieux
très littéralement non pas compris que
moi je m'amusais je m'amusais avec les
gens littéraires
je voulais absolument pas décrire la
violence découper des femmes toutes les
choses dont j'ai été accusé ce qui
m'intéresse c'est l'avantage c'était de
créer
un type de romans nouveau ensuite avec
Glamorama vous traitez du terrorisme 3
ans avant les attentats du 11 septembre
et aujourd'hui vous revenez avec Luna
Park publié chez pavillon Robert Laffont
alors faut bien reconnaître que c'est
assez génial votre livre quand même
c'est assez extraordinaire ça commence
comme une autobiographie classique vous
raconter ce que je viens de raconter
c'est-à-dire l'ascension fulgurante de
l'enfant terrible de la littérature
américaine qui a fait des œuvres à
scandales succès à outrance drogue sexe
qui finissent par vous amener au bord du
gouffre
jusque là rien d'extraordinaire vous
racontez votre vie et là stop vous dites
que vous avez décidé de vous arrêter le
sexe la drogue le glamour c'est terminé
vous avez retrouvé la mère de votre fils
l'actrice Jane Dennis et vous êtes
installé tous les trois dans une
banlieue chic et ennuyeuse c'est-à-dire
qu'à partir de ce moment-là bratislain
lisse va se transformer en bon papa de
la côte Est et l'une à part que continue
comme la chronique tranquille d'une
Amérique suburbaine on est en pleine
autofiction
sauf que c'est faux
et ça c'est génial
c'est fondé sur une vérité émotionnelle
et peut-être qu'il y a 80 sens de regret
de façon de regret je ne suis pas père
je ne suis pas marié alors voilà donc
cette installation de greatest dans une
banlieue chic de la côte Est avec femme
et enfant c'est du pipeau raconte comme
c'était son autobiographie c'est là où
c'est génial alors évidemment pas marié
il a jamais eu de fils la fille
l'actrice hollywoodienne qui l'épouse la
Jane Dennis elle n'existe pas mais il y
a un site internet où il y a la bio de
cette Jane Dennis ça filmographie on dit
même qu'elle a une aventure avec Kean
Reeves donc ils ont monté tout un truc
si tu veux qui qui valide qui valide
cette partie du bouquin et et lorsqu'on
lui posait des questions au début de sa
promotion on lui demandait comment ça va
avec Jane Denis il disait ça va mais
est-ce que la Lune bouquin oui oui il y
a des choses avec lesquelles elle est
pas d'accord mais enfin il a
complètement il est c'est génial
vraiment c'est extraordinaire bravo
merci merci alors il est là dans cette
banlieue en train d'écrire son nouveau
livre qui s'appelle teenage pussy et là
on passe dans une troisième phase du
livre c'est à dire que ça devient un
roman de Stéphane King ça commence à se
déglinguer quoi tout commence à se
déglinguer dans la maison ça dérape à ce
moment-là le bouquin d'érable dans le
paranormal les peluches des enfants
deviennent agressives il y a la moquette
qui pousse il y a le héros d'American
Seiko Batman qui qui commence à hanter
le quartier la maison et là et là on
rentre dans quelque chose de beaucoup
plus personnel la fin du livre j'ai pas
raconté magnifique parce que quand la
peinture de la maison commence à
s'écailler certains moments la maison
pèle littéralement la peinture qui est
dessous la peinture blanche c'est la
peinture de la maison de son enfance et
à partir de là dans le paranormal il va
commencer à à retrouver des choses de
son enfance par exemple il y a ils sont
père évidemment c'est qu'à un moment il
commence à recevoir des mails de la
banque comment une banque peut envoyer
des mails à 3h du matin non mais comme
par hasard la banque envoie des mails à
l'heure de la mort de son père et dans
cette banque dans le coffre de cette
banque il y a les cendres de son père
donc il est ramené comme ça vers son
enfance il revoit la voiture de son père
dans le quartier c'est magnifique
franchement c'est génial vraiment
c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'est un livre magnifique et encore là
t'as pas aimé imagine si tu avais aimé
j'adore ce bouquin alors
est-ce que vous existez encore dans le
monde réel ou est-ce que désormais vous
vivez dans votre univers et dans le
monde des livres britison
malheureusement je vis dans le monde
réel maintenant et c'est tourner
littéraire
au monde à l'heure actuelle ça prend une
grande partie de ma vie c'est à ce point
que j'en suis maintenant et je ne suis
pas sûr parce que l'avenir détient pour
moi je pense peut-être
revenir Los Angeles je sais pas je ne
sais pas ce qui m'attend je passe par
cette période comme si je vivais une
sorte de crise de l'homme de 40 ans et
je suis un peu perdu à la dérive je sais
pas
c'est difficile pour moi de prendre des
décisions maintenant combien de temps
dure votre tournée promotionnelle
mondiale
tourner et beaucoup plus bref que la
dernière on a tiré les leçons de la
dernière la dernière tournée à durer
environ 14 à 16 mois 16 mois de promo
cette fois nous nous sommes débrouillés
pour la concentrer et la dragée donc ça
dure à peu près 4 mois je suis parti de
chez moi en août
j'ai quitté ma maison en août et on est
en quoi maintenant
on arrive
le 7 mars 1964
[Musique]
pour lui en janvier prochain
bien pour moi tant mieux
ils sont très imaginatifs les poissons
merci et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez
un pouce bleu